I want to ask you Lawrence have you ever  understood something that you feel was  sort of as high level a discovery that  you made perhaps for the first time in  human intellectual history if you're a  theorist you often you go through these  phases almost like death of loved ones I  mean sometimes you're just pushing  things forward a little bit but if  you're ever proposing something  particularly new you go through the  stage of love and you think oh this  could really explain things and then it  gets moderated and then generally the  experiments show it's wrong or something  and so you go through this grief period  as well so I've had this hope many times  that that I might be the first one to  understand things but the dark energy  was probably the most concrete example  of potentially sort of being right